we're now taking on the role of
barristers we are trying to demonstrate
the truth or something and we're going
to put out evidence we're going to use
arguments the tool that we have is logic
okay so that will be different to say
scientifically experimenting with this
would be taking the properties that
we're about to put onto here right you
can see them written in front of you and
we're gonna label them on diagram and
then just drawing this diagram again
again an experiment you'd say well what
if this is five centimeters and this is
eight you know can we demonstrate this
can we measure it and find an angle do
it again do again and again and again
that's what experimentation means
repeated observation the survey of
mathematics is no instruments no
repetition required you just do it once
and it's true everywhere in forever
read the question with me because I
don't have all the information on my
diagram that's on theirs okay it starts
off by saying KL equals M L so have a
look at where I've labeled everything
where's KL it's yeah it's this vertical
side yeah yeah Malaysian capital thank
you very much my parents are from there
anyway so KL equals n L they give us
another pair of lengths that are also
equal which are they and wait which ones
l m n it's this guy over here and M Pei
is that right okay good have I got all
the information yes
okay so he's our stage right from here
we can find evidence we can construct an
argument we're trying to find what X is
and prove that it has to be that not
just like oh it sort of looks like that
or I think you know I did this a couple
of times and this is what came out to be
we're gonna prove what it is so let's
begin by starting in the shape that we
know the most about okay that's a that's
a really good general strategy go for
the shape we know the most about is this
triangle on the left hand side okay
because you know some things are its
sides you also know this angle over here
okay so being we know this angle what
statement can we make that gets us
toward these other angles over here what
statement can we make yeah
angle lkm let's all write this down
together Aryans suggesting this angle up
here is equal to angle what was it again
aim out and okay now because proof means
you've got to use an argument right it's
not enough just to say it even if it is
true I must provide a reason what is the
reason there's at least two ways I could
say this any suggestions checking I
could say this is an isosceles triangle
over here MLK and sides in my sausage
triangle are equal that's fine okay
however that's actually a longer way
around because I don't know
nowhere in the question has actually
said the words MLK bless you is an
isosceles triangle right
not to mention don't draw this but have
a look at this here's an isosceles
triangle right this angle over here in
the bottom right hand corner is clearly
not equal to this angle at the top yeah
so you can't just say any two angles you
want like whichever ones you happen to
pick a better way to say this and this
is what I'm going to suggest you right
here is that equal angles are opposite
equal sides do you remember in the same
rule how when we draw the triangle
you're like what here's it some
information here you get an angle over
here and it's opposite and angle over
here and it's opposite well if the two
angles are equal the sides end up equal
as well equal angles are opposite sorry
I missed a word that's better equal
sides okay they oppose they face each
other that's good what can I do with
this because now I know these are equal
I'll mark them as such but how can I use
that to further my argument yeah
okay and LM 90 degrees yes so because we
have this 90 degree here this 90 degrees
is related to these two they're all in
the one triangle do you agree
what do we know think back a couple
lessons about the angle sum of a
triangle 180 now this is really
important we're gonna produce a
statement here to argue this it's about
the angle sum of a triangle so what I
want to put in this next line is a sum
of angles right so I'm gonna go l k m
plus l m k plus k L M this is literally
the angle sum of the triangle because
I've got every single one and I've added
them up that is what an angle sum is
after all it's equal to what was that
sighs again 180 don't forget to put
degrees okay
just like before we need a reason okay
I'm gonna need a bit more space here my
reason is just like we were just saying
the angle sum of I'm gonna encourage you
to arm name the triangle you're talking
about not just because it shows you
understand the diagram better okay
and it's actually faster to write than
just say a triangle so that's a bonus
it's 180 degrees please note I haven't
written that some angle is 180 take away
something take away something that's not
a sum it's a difference right so I want
my argument to be as watertight as
possible this statement matches this
reason in the closest way possible okay
I know what some of these things are I
just said that these two were equal
what's this one it's 90 degrees so on
the next line I'm going to do a
substitution that shows all of that I'm
gonna say it wrong color I'm gonna say L
okay M plus L K M you see they're the
same angle I proved that up in this
first line plus 90 degrees equals 180
okay so I've just done a substitution
from
listen to this listen to this so how
many okay ohms do I have on left-hand
side two of them through lots of L km
that's an angle sign it's an angle sign
it's not a great angle same ol I'll give
you that angle so if I subtract 90
degrees from both sides I end up with 90
over here so what's the size of lkm I'm
dividing both sides by 2 which gives me
45 degrees okay now I'm going to pause
for a moment I have helped you out and
held your hand through something like
the first half of this proof okay I
haven't got to what I'm trying to get to
so I'm going to pause and give you a
couple of minutes to put together your
argument have a look at the information
we now know see how can you you can use
it to get out of this triangle over into
this other one I'll give you a head
start and then I'll put my answer on the
board okay off you go